[Music]
we try a little bit too in this tutorial
to bring up bring different technologies
together and show how we use Python 2 to
combine standards from the juice facial
community and get our data from the
ECMWF and there's a bit at the beginning
a bit of explanation to do so we start
off a bit a talk but then we have three
sessions to go into more practical work
and as I mentioned there's two links you
might want to have a quick look at now
is the first one it's a hosted service
of the Jupiter notebooks if you go there
you will be able to follow straightaway
the course or you can go that the second
link is it on github where you can find
the Jupiter notebooks cloned them or
download it as a zip file and then
follow it for that but then you have to
sort things to be installed yourself
that's on your machine and it's better
dependencies like always live matplotlib
all the libraries we need for the
florida tutorial are already installed
so it's a safer environment where you
can run everything yes if you can try
the first link a requires that I'd given
authorization so github yeah so you have
to log in with your guitar credential
without mine ok yeah yeah I think what I
want you can just blown it with from
guitar but then you need all the library
spaces yes and libraries my problem I
guess most of you will have there's net
city netcdf 4os lip and unfortunately at
the moment you need a no-slip with a
fake so there's a link to another git
repository you need to follow
unfortunately that's why we set up the
the other environment
please also in I mean this is the first
time we're trying this kind of tutor so
if you have any question please raise
your hand we look into it
change like any information and
silhouettes that we have a like we have
a black channel to different people
for this focus that try underscore
bargainer so if you have your on the
slack team just for that channel in
Jordan extends 24 such an example
oh we fit with the first link Oh
actually somebody managed to do you got
it fine okay
can you perhaps we try to see this just
perhaps the same time yeah I just wonder
types of building it did it did it
time out again
I've loaded it so I was running or
anything okay but it's you you were able
to to load it it's a quick hand sign who
has problems at the moment if you could
perhaps try again and otherwise if you
could switch to the github there's
anything lost and except for all of us
to be honest the standard oh slip will
actually work for some part of it so
there's an in a notebook a link which
which like the most of this relationship
okay
yes that's easy to yeah okay good do you
think you need a bit more time to still
come out so I think then that's a good -
yeah yeah I think that might be good but
once we do everything 22.7 I mean we try
things other mm I know I know I know
and what the perps do is and I start
with the general presentation little bit
so and then we check after that how
everybody has gone on with the fillings
unfortunately means I cannot keep the
links up so everybody can take them now
and okay a quick hand sign who has heard
of ECMWF before Wow more than I thought
and the European Centre for medium-range
weather forecast is an intergovernmental
international organization which is
located in reading here in the UK west
of London and and we are quite a small
organization about 300 people even so we
are called European we're actually not a
directly linked with the European Union
so and you can see from our member
states that we are we're not exactly the
same Member State at the European Union
we have a different member state and
some of the European Union are not
member state of us and two
intergovernmental independent M what we
do is we're doing better forecasting
numerical weather forecasting and what
our mission is to support national
weather service's and of the general
weather in the industry with a
medium-range weather forecast which
means anything from three days and
beyond
so it's normally three to fifteen days
it's a what's called medium-range
forecast and it makes sense to actually
work internationally together because
wherever you want in the world to make a
three day forecast or anything
longer-term you need to global forecast
you can one or two days you can get away
with looking at a local situation but
anything beyond two days you will have
to need look a global model so instead
of all these countries running their own
global model that came together in the
70s and decided let's have one
supercomputer center which does it all
for us and then we can use it from them
and we say it's a more efficient to do
it all together and so we had 24/7
operational centers with twice a day
we're issuing our forecast which go to
the weather services not only in Europe
but around the world it's very time
critical job it's a lot of data if we're
generating it
terrabytes is for each forecast and we
have often archives which now reach over
hundred 80 petabytes of data so it's
very temporary certain very large data
sets we have and to cope with all that
and to push forward because you can
imagine forecasting up to 15 days is
quite a challenge
we have also very strong research focus
which is not all done at the center
we're bringing together different
research activities around Europe and
coordinate them and also work with them
and to cooperate and member says I
mentioned and because of our core
activity we are also operating on behalf
of the European Union to services for
them you might have heard about
Copernicus Copernicus is an initiative
of the European Union the European Union
has been for decades a big driver and
supporter and sponsor of work research
work on Earth observation and
environmental services but there were
mostly short-term so some years back
they came together and said let's have a
long-term program which is goes beyond
to three years projects and there's the
Copernicus program and there's different
services two of them the climate change
service and the atmospheric monitoring
service they are hosted or operated by
ECMWF and as you can imagine climate
change services the aim is to support
businesses and Industry to prepare for
changing climate and prepare for that
and make decisions on on fugitive on
future projects atmospheric monitoring
service is more direct link to our usual
businesses about forecasting the quality
air quality pollution and assist also
governments and businesses to react to
these challenges and yes I think that's
so ECMWF a quick word about our data and
we have a open data but our core
forecast data is not freely available as
I said we're support English and weather
services so they take the data they're
including it and then they will issue
forecast out of this one so they use
this forecast and then give it further
and then we have a lot of public data
sets everything actually is funded by
the European Union is actually open and
accessible they're very keen on this one
because I really want to encourage that
businesses and agencies picking these
services up that's why also we are
interested with projects like the one we
are working here to find ways how can
the community businesses get our data
and how they can build services and new
applications for the community for
businesses but there we have different
services and in from to climate change
that is you will have something called
reanalysis reanalysis is going back when
people talk about climate change or we
think about the future but important
part is also to go back in the past and
reanalyze which was the weather in the
past so that you can see patterns and
how the climate has evolved and to make
some prediction for the future so that
is what this is when you see reanalysis
mentioned here that's what this is then
we bring in different forecasts together
around the world and focuses on we don't
look at what just one forecasting model
they look around the world at different
centers what they're forecasting and we
have some research datasets where we
bring these datasets together so they're
not real time but they allow researchers
and businesses to to learn from it and
it's very interesting in the age of
machine learning to look back at past
data to learn from for future decisions
and building new application how you
want to use weather data and I mentioned
already that I'm saying monitoring
service so just to say that not all our
data is afraid you will see the excess
we have to access our data's Web
Services that
you will have to provide a token and the
toka me you see is public there's other
tokens but their IP address limited so
you cannot assess it but the public one
you should be able to assess at least a
couple Anika services and some of our
data which is free so our data itself
and we're doing America weather forecast
which has the advantage that the data is
actually quite structured and quite
predictable because it's an America
model so we don't have much on the sense
of missing data or outliers very much so
it's output from the America weather
forecast but what is more challenging is
a dimension the various dimensions we
have so if weather forecast is not only
a geospatial in Latin long it also goes
in time and then we're also going into
height and in height in weather
forecasting you're not go in geometrical
high do not go 5,000 meters I you go in
a pressure levels so we talk about 500
packed hectopascal as a height and this
is simply how weather is moving it's a
long pressure levels is not the weather
does not care what is the geographical
height it cares about where the
pressures of the atmosphere so it makes
sense for for metrology but also users
like in in the aviation they are also
used to working with pressure levels so
you would see that coming up in the
thing then we have something different
which brings us to five dimension and
that is we're not just running a one
forecast
we're running actually 51 forecast and
the idea is that you actually run a set
of forecast calls in Istanbul and you
actually you have one which you start
with the best starting condition you
have at the time of the atmosphere and
then you start 50 with slightly changed
condition and then you can see from how
these 51 forecast behaves statistically
you can have have an indication of the
certainty of your forecast so 20
forecast agree then you have you can see
that there's probability into a forecast
or 50 agree
you can be very certain if you have not
more than 3/4 agreeing on a wetter
pattern than its high uncertainty about
if this will happen so it helps
forecasters to predict the certainty of
a focus but this is of course very
time-consuming and data consuming so
it's quite a challenge for users of our
data to download all this data make
statistics so that we have some products
like mean and spreads values which
already calculated over all these
ensembles so M coming to the end of the
presentation part M what we now want to
do is we're going to go a general
geospatial data workflow so the first
thing is of course getting the data as I
said normally when you might have data
project you might have a lot of to do
clean up the data things because it
comes out of a numerical model which is
the very ideal situation you actually
don't have to do so much cleanup work if
the data is actually quite quite clean
and can be straight used but still you
want to do some data processing for your
for your analyzed analysis but you also
want perhaps to subset data you want to
have time series so that we will explain
a little bit how you can do that and
then you want at the end of course a
nice little picture so of something you
can prevent so visualization is always
quite important so it goes from the
excess processing to the visualization
and I mean over over this protests you
will reduce the value of the volume of
the data but hopefully what you get is
you get more information out of this
because in the end even if you have much
less data at the end on your small.png
possibly it should really have something
much more information for the users than
all the data you have so we have at the
end some more links if you're interested
to find out about ECMWF about our data
service catalog if you're interested to
browse a little bit definitely don't
have time here and and then also about
for example the climate data service and
a server - also the two plus I should
mention that is actually the project
where Jillian and I here for
it's a project we have of the European
Union sponsored it's a three year
project to explore how we can use
standard geospatial weapons done
web services to bring our data out we
have already existing services to
pushing out a huge amount of data but
they're very specific there there have
been proven over the last thirty years
but they're very specific to our
community and they're very hard to use
for non their people for users outside
our community so we are looking at
standards like the OGC standards which
are well established to work with them
so that if you interface to our data you
have the same effort as you have of
other services and you not have to do
anything special for ECMWF this is the
earth of a - project and we're having a
test service with julia we'll talk later
about and which we use for that and
doing before my voice goes yeah I'm
going over now to the first a first
tutorial I don't know how we are for
time um okay and I mention already ODC
web servers at quick hands and who knows
about ODC web services whoo Wow less
than smw that I have to write down and
because and we're using them because
we're told everybody uses them so that's
the ha
no it's M starting in the 90s website
gives a bit background information
starting in the 90s it became very clear
that there's more and more services
where there's geospatial data geospatial
data means any data set you have which
has any coordinate the coordinates
involved on earth so so the idea came up
let's build is standards for the web how
I can retrieve these kind of information
and ODC the open geospatial consortium
is in it's an organization which is it's
located in the US but it's quite
international now it's quite popular in
Europe so a lot of especially government
organizations are involved with the ODC
the European Union has has its inspire
program inspire program is where they
trying to encourage more and more
government data to be available freely
and easily accessible and they have also
decided to go mostly with the OGC
standard so that means they're quite
popular I think you will find there's a
lot of OGC based standards around where
you can get public datasets in different
countries if you if you want to find
them out Google for inspire and your
country and you should get a portal
which gives you the different data
access for us of course working the
Europeans is also very interesting to
use these standards because they really
want us to use it Oh GC is in it's a
family of standards and because when you
have to use spatial data you can have
you can have vector data which we
normally don't have because we do if you
have ordered a data of borders
coastlines there is not read our
business but you might have as a street
a road maps or something so you you have
these kind of vector information they
have something called a web feature
service which will not talk about today
and and then on the other hand they have
rusta data and that's exactly the data
we have coming out of an American model
this is data which covers a wider area
so that it's not only metrological
fields of satellite imagery that's
actually the main driver in the most
popular in these services and then also
digital elevation models this WMS is
actually quite long around it's used a
lot in the back where you get maps when
you introduce it often it's used for
like Google Earth something to integrate
a new map layer or something so it's
tandem which is quite widely used but
possibly not always visible to users but
it allows users to get a data and
there's there's a different standards
which Julia will cover bit the web
coverage service that cover its
processing service these are the two we
will talk about and then it's the
coverage traditional one we're not
talking today about in-between is
another stuff they whatever I mentioned
the web map service where you get maps
and images this is what what is mostly
used as I said and but we are mostly
interested in the maps which I will
quickly go an example but then the main
example of what we interested with a
server is the data because the data will
allow you as a user possibly to build
your application in
images are nice but you have to get what
is provided you have less flexibility
with that the data will allow you to
build service especially for get a time
series you can build an application with
that showing your time to vote for your
location okay
and just to quickly show how it looks
and a WMS this is now the web map
service start with what most standards
have is they have one web core URL
called called get capabilities and that
is actually an XML document and
sometimes quite big one which describes
what the service is offering in case of
a vet map services the layers the
graphical layers of maps you can can
request from the service and then you
have another request to get the map just
to quickly show how that looks if you
want if you see the links on your thing
you can also click them as you have
learned it ok and and if you can see add
up please don't look at it because
they're massive big documents but the
good thing is they're machine readable
so you can write scripts you can write
on your web on the web client side you
can write scripts but also on Python web
site you can access this information I
will show you in a second how from
Python so you get all the information
you need to make use of the service and
then as an example here is one example
how you can get this map it's already
there sorry and and this is for example
now one layer I requested from our
service and you can see that it's
actually that's transparent background
so if your overlay you don't see where
there's no data but it's the map and of
course you want to somehow integrate it
because you need to know what area that
is that is you might get it worldwide
but it could have been a sub area over
Europe or something so and there's
something you have to do on your client
site and understand what this request is
and if you look at the request it's a
simple form you're just saying I want
the layer composition of AUD and 500
that's a challenge to know what this is
you want to quickly do they give my
voiceover okay trust the question that
the people wanted to access the stock to
the house be able to okay sorry about
the timeout that they're going to
talking like if you tried and then you
should be eventually able to access to
Buddha okay good so we Stephan already
introduced you to a web mapping service
and the that coverage service has the
same structure to actually access the
data so we also have a get capabilities
document where we get the information
about the service and also what data we
can actually access from the service so
it basically looks the same it's an XML
document but it helps you in the end
they are like what specific data we can
access like your discharge data or Jeff
fire better index data for example and
then we in abet coverage service because
we have like an overview of what data is
available but if we want to have more
specific information to one specific
data set like for example the bounding
boxes or the temporal coverage and
there's a request we can use to say okay
describe me the coverage and then the
coverage ID I'm interested in is
temperature to two meters for example to
immediate temperature and the request
looks like this so we change the request
type to describe coverage and then we
say we interested in the coverage ID
temperature two meters and if we open
this then we get also an XML document
but then with much more information
about the geographical extent and also
the temporal extent and also the number
of rows and number of like the number of
pixels or valid data points for valid
data points so it gives us more
information and we can now better
group of the data so we know it's a
global data set and it's available from
1979 to 2000 and 2016 basically yeah
and though this is like just getting the
metadata and some information if we
really want to get the data out of the
service without required download there
is the request get coverage and there we
say okay get the coverage we also
specify the coverage ID in this case
also timber to media temperature and in
within the request we can also subset
our data so for example if we interested
in just one time time information but
the entire global information we can say
subset equals and then we just do a
subset on the time axis so antsy and
then in this example we do 15th of
December 2013 but the same we also could
do for subsetting latitude or longitude
if we just interested in Europe for
example Africa and in this case I
specify format also as an XML but we
will later see later that there's also
other formats available which is more
useful or my more more handy to work
also within the pythons grouped and so
this is an XML and in here we see
actually the actual data values okay
so this is the request types for WCS so
get capabilities describe coverage and
get coverage and then because geospatial
data are usually large in volume so we
have to process the data and actually to
reduce the volume and to get the
information we actually need and but we
don't want to download the data so best
is actually do have to processing right
at the server side and though with these
web services and especially with the web
coverage processing service which is an
extension of the web coverage service we
we have an opportunity to actually
process directly the data on the server
and just get information we actually
need
and this looks like it's a similar
sql-like language so basically we use
then a request
it's called process coverages and then
we build up queries for our data and so
in this case we say okay for all for
every point in our coverage ID be
interested for in temperature 2 meters
please give us back the the entire
global field but we want only to have
two subsets on the 31st of December 2015
and at the same time we want to convert
the 2 meter air temperature data from
Kelvin to degrees Celsius so basically
we just we get back the converted field
in the end and then from this web
coverage processing service it takes a
while we get to use feedback which we
can then easily integrate or store into
an umpire array which we will show a
show later ok so this is enough theory I
would say we now get our hands dirty
with some examples how to access the
data with web mapping service yes I
guess you wonder why on payday 2 pi data
we are talking not about prices so we
now start actually to go tight and white
M as it's really said we start off with
WMS simply because it's it's the most
how we can say most used most
established of all these OTC services
and because it gives you a visual result
it's also the easiest one to show
something it has something visually to
show you and what we're using Python for
I mean we're also relatively new to pi
Simeone over the last years starting to
use python and also now jupiter
notebooks for training we are also only
really starting now but what did bring
brings nicely for us is that we can
bring all these things together these
OGC standards our data and allow users
now really to do something with our data
easily which can be very well trained
through these jupiter notebooks but also
very exchanged and then later in the
scripts can be also
as an application so m and ii mentioned
earlier the key for assessing OGC
standard is actually a library called
OWS lip and for the WMS you can use the
standard OWS which is on your system if
you have it installed and it's under pip
it's a very common package and the
Python widely available definitely a 2.7
sorry mm but I'm sure it's also on the
under 3 and so if you get this if you
want to perhaps if you want to follow it
with what we have done is we actually
get very kindly prepare everything out
for you so you can step-by-step
following through I assume that
everybody is okay with going through
Jupiter notebooks anybody want to click
go through I mean if you just want to go
through step-by-step executing these
different steps and what you do is you
if you highlight like here I do now if
it is a cell one and you get a green
border if you just type space return and
then you will execute this this one what
you will see is you will see above the
Python to adjust this small circle as
long it's dark is actually means
processing on the very top now it's
white in them because it has stopped
processing the first step you did not
there was not much to see but it's the
second one where we now we now did the
request to the WMS to get back an object
and that is now the WMS as I mentioned
from from ECMWF and we use the token
public so you get all the public WMS
services returns and you can list the
contents of it by going in your second
bar say WMS dot contents and then
hopefully you should all see a list of
the content of what you can ask from the
WMS it's a nice long list and you might
say oops what is all this because if
you're not familiar with some of the
terms I mean you will get what grid and
rivers is but all the others might be a
bit more yeah
not known so what you can do is you can
next thing you can ask the title of each
of these layers if you want to see what
they do so if you go to this cell and
execute it you can then find that the
composite co2 surface is the carbon
dioxide at surface and that is a typical
example of what they say climate and
then the Copernicus atmospheric
monitoring service does one of these
parameters they provide so if you want
perhaps a quickly take you might have
another layer you wonder what they mean
if you want to take a name and want to
try it out so you replace it you can use
the same cell if you want and then
execute it and then see that to get
their explanation from that but this
also means if you build an application
you want to build a title in your
application of what product you have you
can use this information directly from
it and that should be hopefully a
self-contained description of course
what is every car that's it's that's a
different matter but I think it's there
are some projects which you have to
refer to possibly from them then you can
get other information for example very
important is to find out when you have a
WMS you need to find out what are you
actually get which location in the case
of ECMWF is quite easy because as you
can see from this example the bounding
box in lat/long is actually it's the
whole globe and most of our products I
think with very few exceptions they're
all global so it makes it relatively
easy if you work of other OGC web map
services you might find that you need to
check this to see that you overlay it
correctly in what areas which we covers
a lot of service in the US only covering
for example the US so you would have to
all in lot of national services just
covering their own national area so it's
worth checking whatever you get and as I
said for ECMWF is quite relatively easy
and I said with the WMS of course when
you get the visualization of a parameter
back then it has to be styled
how and we have different styles that
which we offer and that's not the most
web map services do they have a range of
styles to offer and it's not always easy
to know what's behind these the names
but what you can do is you can ask for
each layer if you have interested in one
layer you can you can ask with saying
dot styles you can see what styles are
offering so then you can choose any of
the styles provided there so here you
can see the different styles mentioned
for the composition to you to a surface
and just to check but I think that is
also very common is which services which
operations this service lets you Mehta
do they get car bilities we already have
done in the back because we got all the
information of the layers get map we
already mentioned that is the map and
then there's another feed another
operation called get future info and
that is unfortunately something where
the standard is very vague and just says
give you can give to this function you
get give a location within the bounding
box and then it should give you
information back about this location
unfortunately a standard says is
absolutely operator to do and that means
that where the standard goes out and
that's where it's hard as a programmer
application the web to rely on what
you're getting back is though assume
that we have service you get the value
at this location whatever layer you have
but in other places is you get actually
a little graph of the time series for
example so it depends what you get back
to you this is something if you go for
different in web map services you need
to check very carefully and what the
service replies and then you can check
which kind of graphical products you get
back what normally most services do and
what the easiest to rely on it's a PNG
because you can put it everywhere that
perhaps the easiest one
SVG PDF PostScript are or the Google
Earth one they are more defensive ones
if you want to overlay something but the
PNG is now we come to you can very
easily especially also venue
have like this jupiter notebooks is more
easier to integrate than the others so
now we have played a little bit get some
information from the service now it's
actually we want now to to plot
something so here's some example code
how to get three different layers from
our service and how to overlay them and
plot them within the the jupiter
notebook the first thing is to have to
overlay anything graphical format what
you do with MATLAB lips in jupiter
notebooks you have to have this a magic
line of the percentage macro clip in
line that ensures whatever you do this
it goes in line and then we include the
method of lip image in pi plot
we have provide you an example of a
method which can make it easier if you
do a lot of routine a map-request
you might actually want to have a method
or something which does it for you
because there will be a lot of
parameters you will repeat for example
you will always use the same format type
you might want to share the same
projection and these kind of information
you want to actually always the same for
your map so you can put them in a method
and then you can reduce your calls for
the get map to what we call here to get
map method and then you have a simpler
code for that but what we do here is we
actually as you saw in the example i've
done earlier if you request one layer
you've just get the layer there's no
there's no information with it where the
location actually is so as a support for
that we offer a various layers like
we're using here the background which is
actually the you can see it's the
landmass shaded in this nice how you
call the color can
beige yes yes beige skin color and there
is a default background and then the for
foreground is actually the the coastline
to go with it so these are the two
layers which we put here just for the
orientation what this code allows you
you can change it and you can take the
data NASA has a nice web map service on
the data called it's a blue earth blue
blue marble blue marble yes so you could
actually take that as a background
instead of this fantastic base you want
if you want something more interesting
or something more more vibrant so this
is business your option now with the WMS
that you have every layered separate you
can actually take them from different
services so um so what I would suggest
is if you want perhaps to spend five 10
minutes on this example might want to
change the layers is please also feel
free to change the the location I mean
here this is now global you might want
to try Europe or something like that try
to play around a little bit and with the
WMS very directory of like services that
use the standards and also their
earnings you've got a very global one
here the one to do so he would look at
UK
that there's there's qualitative
unfortunate not eerie registry there are
some pages where where they were
different people were trying to build
these kind of it but there's sometimes
out of date now and you will find that
there's a lot of services have come and
go I have been renamed and there's quite
a lot in the US there is a said there's
actually every every member of the
European Union has now to have four
inspire these national services where
they have to your data is the inspire
portal of the UK should have some layers
the inspire inspire UK so there you
should audit data to data graph yes yeah
later disgustoid UK I think that's a
linguist that yeah
so there there you should find a lot of
services actually but there's a lot of
that map services but as I said there
will be it there will be different
location then there will be there's
definitely want to check the boundary
rocks what areas are covering anybody
has else a question so easy
yes do we sample of the data before it's
Angela yes how do you know what point
you start so something woke me
it's very hard to judge and from from a
client site when you do that I agree
it's it that is not that's not I can say
the ideal thing off the bat what you can
actually do is you can if you leave it
away you should get the highest so and
all that stays right there you expect
that is the service provider is when
they set up the service they specify and
what would be the default and ideally it
should be the best resolution so you
normally only give it if you want to
have it smaller so that's ideally does
not mean that everybody does it like
that of course it's but the standard
allows you to set a default it normally
is suggested to use the most quality one
so ideally if you leave it away it
should get no but then you have to be
careful with aspect ratio and think that
so yes does not come out of the box you
might have to apply the steps but it's a
bit there's a bit of trial and error on
fortune but everybody is able to follow
and to know no blue marble is actually a
web map service from NASA or it's
actually the NASA did from took
satellite images of the earth and build
a mosaic of the earth with clouds
removed and things it's a very very nice
sleek view of the earth and they provide
this as when you go blue with such blue
marble now in NASA you will find to have
a picture you can get these
high-resolution JPEGs and TIFF but they
also have a web map service where they
serve it out exactly exactly that's the
nice thing with the standard old WMS you
should be able to assess through the
voice level exactly the URL we get in
the beginning of all these government
faces they all stick to a standard today
and depends what they're serving because
you will find them might be from the UK
I think there's some about Streep is
tribute in information for roads and
streets and that will be vector data so
they use the web feature service so it
will it does not have to be all coverage
oh there's a web map service so they
have different services yeah yeah but
they're trying as much as I know to
follow the OGC standards yeah
yeah
yes
sorry for my father not even Indians
doing something wrong with her document
is not easy to define
yeah did you put a global bounding box
in here and use it anywhere the global
are here I okay hang on I'm not quite
sure like it's okay I hang on a few if
you go up and this obsessive but and we
can see of a base over here so we see a
latitude Richard minimum that longitude
minimum latitude now another oh yeah
yeah okay
so we'd like to have a bit more time or
shall we continue because we would now
switch from the web mapping service to
the web covered service maybe yeah okay
okay good so now we actually interest it
because we have large volumes of data to
get the real data values and also to
process the data to get actually
information we were interested in and
not predefined maps and layers so and we
are there is also from this outlet
library the standard one is supports
also about coverage service but just a
web coverage service version 1.0 which
doesn't support the processing
functionality and then our server is
also the already diversion 2.0 so that's
why we a colleague of ours he modified
the outlet library and basically you can
fetch it from from this github account
here to that the outlet library also
supports web coverage service of the
version 2.0 yeah yeah yeah so we in the
process that it actually supports also
2.0 soon but on the to Peter HAP's
basically we already installed this
version of the outlet so it actually
should work so we start off actually
with the same the same way as we start
with the web mapping service we build a
object with our web coverage service
which is your the where L to our service
and then we can specify and we can see
actually to see what data is actually
available on the service where we go
from our opt object-- from all over
coverage service object we go to
contents and then the keys we want to
actually get the coverage
names and if we let it run you should
also get all the different coverages
available from the service so soil
moisture temperature on two meters
temperature on pressure levels river
discharge forecast data etc if we want
to get a list of available properties
coverage half we can we can use this
with the the key contents and then
specify on what coverage we actually
interested in so in this case two meter
air temperature but we can also specify
sea surface temperature for example or
particulate matter 25 so we go through
and then we can see we get we can get
information on access description
bounding box the grip definitions
different supported formats etc so if II
so now we know what data is available
but still if we specifically interested
in one dataset we want to know like what
are the what day what what
specifications does this data set have
like so what bounding box from one what
temporal cont
context we can use the data etc so for
example this the key contents and then
our data we interested in and then
bounding boxes we can see what actually
what bounding box the data refers to and
here we have to apologize or at a moment
we have some difficulties because we
come from the metrological domain and
the t is domain usually works with
pixels and the metrological domain works
with data points and so there are
differences how to specify a grid on our
data and as a because I come from a GIS
background if I see data with minus
ninety point two five I wouldn't trust
the data but it's just at a moment
because
one one idea of this project is to see
how we can actually map the metrological
data on a web coverage service and
though we're working on it
to make it right and we can say the data
at the moment they are right and
actually it's going from minus 90 to 90
and minus 180 100 to 170 9.775 okay
and then and we can also get some more
information about the entire grid our
data contains so if we use instead of
bounding boxes we use the grid parameter
or the grid key then we get the grid
information and then after while it
gives us it tells us that our data is a
three dimensional data set with latitude
longitude and unci in this case is the
time axis and so we have three
dimensions we have the number of pixels
or data points available and also be the
resolution for every axis so in this
case we have a 0.5 x 0.5 latitude
longitude grid and here 0.25 per day so
basically every six hours as our hour is
the temperature available and then we
see the origins so here
the latitude it starts at 90 the
longitude at minus 180 and the the time
information starts at so here we also
have to offset again it starts actually
on first of January 1979 so this is we
now have more information about the data
or we interested in and then because now
actually with large volumes of data we
not specifically interested in JPEG or
PNG so not in image format we actually
interested in data formats we can
actually work with so either to get the
raw data wires
CSV or a netcdf file does are you
familiar with netcdf format no okay so
basically a netcdf format is quite quite
often used in climate sciences so it's
very hard to save it there's there's a
good good library also from Python and
basically it can store multi-dimensional
data within one data file and also the
older metadata that belongs to this to
the parameters basically and so yeah so
climate scientists or also GIS people or
visit us background they often use
netcdf data files so basically we can
see in what formats our data we can
actually retrieve from a web coverage
service and so there are different
options so we can retrieve the data in a
CSV in orissa JSON which is actually
very useful if I want to do web
application for example and then also
normal image formats such as PNG JPEG
and TIFF but this is not what we
interested in on a web covered servic
service and specifically so if we want
to use the our slip library to actually
get get get the data is we can use the
get coverage request on our WS object
and then we can specify like what data
we interested in also what subsets so if
we want to have the global image or a
geographical subset and also the format
we interested in so in this case we
interested in a net CDF for a global
coverage for the first of August 2003
and then it is basically downloaded and
then we can load it with the net CDF for
library
and we can directly plot it so basically
we we request here the file the file is
downloaded and stored and then with and
then we open the netcdf file and we with
the and we construct the data set object
from the net PDF library and this data
set object we can then plot plot with
MATLAB for example so if we let run let
it run there could I just want to
mention it could come to some problems
with if we run it everyone because we
are limited space and a trooper top and
so we have seven gigabytes and one so I
think we sixty people can run it and
then we we will see but it's also good
to test our our services and systems now
basically this is without any so weak
without a lot of data download basically
we could get an information we needed
and just before some lines of code we
reload we could load our data any
questions so far no yeah
sorry so you can produce animations yes
so basically you can from a netcdf file
you can also get because now we
downloaded a two-dimensional file but
you can also store three-dimensional
file and then you can go through the
time information for example and you can
produce yeah videos or just for
animations yes okay so then I would
continue to another so this is this was
actually how we could benefit from the
outlet library but still this was shown
that we still have to download the data
and then load the data again and with
our volumes of data for example one
parameter of 2 meter air temperature
from 1979 to 2014 we have like twenty
seven gigabytes so we actually don't
want to download a lot of data
dublicate data and so we actually want
to get the data or access the data
process them on the server side and just
get information we really interested in
and so another way to actually work with
a web coverage service and a web
coverage processing service is to
request the data with a HTTP request and
then store the data directly in a numpy
array for example or in a Python list
and though in this in this example we
aim to retrieve a time series of global
monthly averages of 2 meter air
temperature and storages supplies in the
inner Python list and here as I told or
as I explained before we take advantage
of the process coverage request so
basically we already process data while
we access it and so the access point is
again our web coverage service the
request type is process coverages and
then we specify AWC PS query in this
case it's still very simple and
understandable
so basically we're going to have for
every point in the 2 meter air
temperature please give us back from
2001 1st of January 2001 to 31st of
January 2001 the 2 meter our temperature
in degree Celsius not in Kelvin and we
want to have for this for for the global
data and average so we want just to have
one one value the average two media
temperature for every day for 4 January
so in this case we specify the URL which
we which we can access our data and we
specify it as a generic well so
basically we can also apply it for other
coverages or other parameters we
interested in and also other time
information be interested in so this is
our our form or request we can use
generally and then because we do we yes
so we need some because we be interested
in just retrieving the data from January
and February and March and April we have
to have a helper list for handling these
date/time objects so this is just a two
for two for loops which help us to
specify the start date in the end date
of every month so 30th of January 28th
of February etc so basically just and if
we look here so the start date list
gives us then a
should give us something is so gives us
now like a list for the year 1979 and
the same for the end date list for every
last day okay and with this information
we can now loop through the generic
where L request we set up before and we
build up our where L or our our request
we interested in to media temperature
and then we just get the information
from the start date list and the end
date list and in the end we want to have
a Python list of the global average for
every month for 1979 so this could this
might take a bit but should actually
work so now we so now with the entire
data is actually accessed and processed
at the same time then we will see yes on
our like on on server side yes we are
descending you are interesting okay I am
interested in a particular parameter on
a particular region indeed by a bounce
of black law or anything as such and you
possess it and you provide that
information back yeah yeah so do if I'm
asking for whole globe as such a
missionary parameters how much time does
it get secret time of what's happening
yeah so this is also part of the project
we investigate so if it is it scalable
and of course with these kind of
services it's very easy to to access
terabytes of data so people wouldn't
recognize that they actually asked for
terabytes of data and so the service
just we have to limit it somehow but in
a moment they will it will not go beyond
but we didn't set a specific limit yeah
yeah okay any other questions
okay okay so now it should have been
and we have now a list of monthly
averages time series for 1979 and the
same we could easily do for another year
or not the global information but just
the geographical subset for example okay
any questions so far
okay okay this was like just how we can
store time to use information into a
Python list but use spatial information
we often have multi dimensional fields
so actually we interested in also to
store directly to access
multi-dimensional data and store them in
the numpy array and then we can work
with them further further and so this is
a more advanced example here so
basically we interested so our two media
air temperature is the three dimensional
data set from like a global data set
from 1979 to 2014 and we want to have
for every click yeah for every month we
want to have the average basically on
but for every data point so we part
instead of because before we just
averaged over every over two-dimensional
field we want to average now through
through time basically through every
month and so there that this is also
possible with this web coverage
processing service but as we see here in
the in the query it gets a bit more
complex so basically we we also process
the data so we converted data from
Kelvin from the from Kelvin to degrees
Celsius but we take like the latitude
longitude and the the time information
and we condense the time the time the
data
um over time and here we see if we
specify a plus here
we say okay please sum it up and then
later on we be divided through the
number of files or through the number of
information we have so we know that this
is like another language people have to
use and this is also we also admitted
it's not very straightforward to
understand but at the same time like if
you have examples like this it also
gives you easily a processing
functionality on top of our data and
multi-dimensional data sets
okay and so in the end we it's a similar
setup here just with the or as before
just with the difference that we have
now a MT numpy array which contains like
the global data field and then for every
month like we have 12:12 global datasets
in the end because we have to be average
for every month basically for 1979 and
this might take now a bit longer - oh
okay I haven't specified this one okay
this might take now a bit longer because
basically we get the entire 1979 data
information and process the data through
Tyus route through time through pseudo
time information but in the end we have
a raster stack we call it of average 2
meter air temperature information for
every month and if we specify here the
with the index 8 then we get the for the
month September for example okay so
they're like any questions I think it's
quite it's also a lot so we gave now to
a different
opportunities how to access the data so
either with the outlook library to play
around with web coverage service or also
directly request the data with HTTP
requests we I don't know how we do it in
time we set up two different examples
how a bed cupboard service and
requesting data via HTTP request could
be very beneficial for some use cases or
to create a geographical workflow we can
do it either two that we have we have
one example that we guide you through
and then another example we you can do
it yourself or we can also guide you
through those examples as you wish no
okay okay okay so basically one example
where we can benefit from the processing
functionality and also where we require
actually a lot of raw data for little
information in the end is a climate
graph for any location and location on
the world basically because the climate
graph contains the long term average
minimum and maximum of the temperature
and also long term average precipitation
for one specific location and for each
month so basically on the raw data we
need a long time series of information
and the best would be to have like
global information because then we can
easily pick any geographical latitude
and longitude so this is actually what
we want to be aim for this is like
mcphillip plot we can also do it
prettier we also see that London is
quite wet okay basically what data is
required and also what data we offer at
ECMWF is reanalysis data what Stefan
said before we have 2 meter air
temperature and also the total
precipitation
from 1st of January 1979 until almost
near real-time like until now April 2016
our data is in group which is a binary
format and even less use than netcdf and
so basically if people are interested in
our data we don't want to have them
using group because it takes quite a
long time to use the data that's why we
interested in building up these services
because then you don't have to think
about any specific format anymore you
just get the data values and you can
easily store it in an umpire array and
then do your processing or your workflow
so basically our data is global data 6
hourly data from 1979 to 2016 or 14 and
the entire data volume is 27 gigabyte
per parameter
so the first day workflow to create a
plot for a climate graph would include
to retrieve first the monthly mean min
and maximum to media temperature from
January 1979 to December 2014 then to
retrieve the monthly sums of total
precipitation so for precipitation be
interested in precipitation sums and not
in the not in the average basically and
then to calculate the average for every
month for every parameter and then once
we have his information we can easily
plot it so we we load some some some
libraries which are required to like
numpy request to to request our HTTP
requests it also mustard lip for example
and because we work with date time we
also use the day time library so we
specify our W CPS queries and this is
the query we also used before so
basically we we take advantage
of a mathematical condenser function so
either average a minimum or a maximum
and though before like before our before
we specify here our our subset of the
data we can you specify a generic
placeholder where we can then later can
specify if we interested in a minimum
the maximum or the average of the data
and so we have two different formats for
the temperature in the precipitation
because temperature we want to convert
from Kelvin to degree Celsius and
precipitation we want to convert from
meters of water to millimeters of water
so okay and here we have the same elbow
functions to go through the entire list
to to specify our first date of day of
the month in the last day of the month
and I just say that I don't let it run
because it would take a longer time we
try to run it and through the stupider
half it it might take like on your local
machine to retrieve the data around 10
minutes because we request 27 gigabytes
but here due for the Jupiter hop its
yeah it took it took a bit longer this
morning
so basically but it's the same here we
just make a cast if we talk about
precipitation we don't start on first of
January 2019 79 but on second of January
1979 because it's forecast data so the
the data has to be processed
specifically and so we only have the day
the process data is only available on
the all starts from the second of
January and then we go through the start
and date end list we would request the
data in our case we can specify the
letter
cute minimum and maximum and a longitude
minimum maximum and also the date
information we get from the stardate
list and end date list and we all store
it in a in a Python this basically and
so so this is our function we we build
up for the functions called retrieved
from WCS and we can we can add to this
function the parameter we interested in
the operation we want to conduct so in
our case what we said what what
condenser function we want to apply so
minimum maximum or average and also the
latitude minimum maximum and longitude
minimum maximum so for for London we
specified the latitude and longitude
information and then we can actually
retrieve three different lists for a
monthly time series for two meter air
temperature and then we interested in
the average in the maximum and in the
minimum and then the latitude and
longitude information has been taken
from from above and the same we do for
the precipitation but just with the
difference that we don't we want to add
so we interested in a precipitation some
rather than an average and so we what we
will generate this list and then we and
then we basically are once we have these
lists we have a function where we then
identifier time series and we retrieve
every information for January every
information for February and then we
generate the average for every month
basically and then we end up with four
different lists of a of the list wealth
values of the of the averages for every
month okay and then we can once we have
this information we can basically plot
it so this is an example this much plot
lip but there are much nicer ways to
to plot it this is just an example and
the plot we already seen seen a bus so
we use the pandas dataframe to bring all
the data together and then to easily
plot it with with MATLAB so this was one
example of a workflow where people can
easily access the data process the data
on the server side and no data download
is basically required to create a
climate graph for for any location any
questions so far
yes no it's just it's just one single
information yes sorry I'm missing the
credited with the other example so this
might might be no it should be faster
but in general we also have to see that
with geospatial data it's it's a bit
depends on the data model how you
structured the data in the database
depending on how users want to actually
access the data and you have to find a
compromise between geographical sub
setting and also time time information
or time retrieval time series retrieval
yes yeah why group or next two years
sorry I agree or next video and so why
we offer the data and group Annette PDF
so you said it like a logical
most of the time it is doing in this
video yeah Grebe's most next lightly
used formatting jyd please it's not the
greatest international standards
exchange America for inspector it is UN
bodies will decide and to ensure for
decades now how because other services
around the world work very closely
together body works very clear standards
to exchange we are not common standards
is actually very much used but ever
forecast you ever get will have been
based on data and performance but you
will never see it's a very closed system
which relies on this one and when I say
we have an 80 megabytes later most of
this is improved forward so we talk
about the amount of data have more juice
than many other formats we think are
more for the users not the commander
States at this moment but it's not like
the users not coming to that not many
tools can handle it it's not very common
outside our specific community very
specific orbit relative density is more
widest crisis core tools or they
so it's used but it's important it's not
if you give it out design you can do
something with it
that's fine
control and it is what was they were
cooking before you introduced I am what
sort of changes and syntek you are
getting about machine yeah now it's a
really good question basically though
yeah the usual juice or the formula to
use facial backflow how also it is
taught at university is you go to to
aside for example to NASA or to ISA or
to eat them double yes you download all
the data you need then you use in either
a geographic information system or if
you already a more advanced then you use
Paisano are to process your data which
worked well can usable when we also
didn't have open data yet and also we
didn't have like these very good data
sets of high resolution now we already
have found introduced a companion
program so it's a new new fleet of
satellites of six different satellites
fleets and we they produce like very
high resolution images and agreed a they
expect to have two terabytes per day
from the satellites basically so
probably most probably users they come
to their limits to process the data on
their local machine to process the data
and also to to store the data somewhere
and also from our perspective as a data
provider it's not our interest that
they're like multiple copies of our data
so our our data archive is at the moment
around 180 petabytes and there is no way
to copy copy this data so it's also
interest to us that not everyone is
actually downloading massive amounts of
data and just getting the data
user actually needs so it's basically
just not not a requirement to download
data anymore and also to apply even if
it's just simple processing
functionalities because with more
advanced data science you yeah you can't
apply on a bit covered service but it
already helps you if you can retrieve
maximum or minimum from server side from
a large data data volume rather than
downloading it and then loading it into
your Python script and calculated from
there yeah that's it respond to your
question already on that data services
just I mean it's an alley is a very very
good thing for machines just that I was
wondering about segue
it was any story that I can cover in a
previous suited to convince people to
use too
about how we get the teacher to have
some sort of a from face to channel
services
okay so XML I would say it's always
machine to missile is it's very powerful
so machine like this like it people I
don't know who if they like it so to go
and his outlet library it basically just
goes through this XML and helps you to
retrieve the information you need rather
than yourself building up the script to
go through the XML document and Jupiter
notebooks like the before with every
workflow like you had the data data from
where stored you had your script
somewhere stored and then you had your
visualization also somewhere so
basically you had like in the
documentation
sometimes it was missing and sometimes
it was there but you had like on
different places the information and
like to put a note books you you have
everything bit one basically yes yeah
yeah
Oh
yeah so it depends on these standardized
OTC web web services yeah yeah so if you
have a web standardized web service and
it follows you standard then you can
also access it yeah so the forecast data
they're not openly available so they
they just available for our member
states and pro far we have like near
real-time data available but not a real
forecast data near real time is about
like for example here are like
reanalysis data it's about the last
month so we have now made like mid of
April now it's available yeah I think
there's some focus they'd like to
encourage is services the air quality
data this is actually available decision
possible so that is it so the new talk
forecast at this forecast
you mean the weather focus like rotation
wait no that is that you get through the
National Agency
and but you will be surprised how many
national agencies have with API not all
ocean sea but the own that API to make a
time series information for location
like the metal detector is that isn't
services for the service nationalism so
you can get information from them
and they have for high resolution event
is other service or support of one and
two days forecast which you might be
older but this place was exploring
goodness with other service what they
offer there's a lot of good is lot of
the projects and ideas now to open up
data ok I think we almost towards the
end that's why I suggest so we prepared
another example of a few spatial data
workflow which climate scientists often
interested in I don't who don't go
through this example specifically
specifically because it's a bit more
complex but we try to document it as
much as possible and basically in this
example we interested in retrieve these
information like this graph probably a
lot of people already seen that we have
global warming warning a forming and
yeah our globe is getting warmer and
also like to this general information
from the entire globe and then we can
also get for specific monkeys
information and basically you can also
create these kind of graphs based on our
data and with the help of these web
coverage services and you don't have to
download the data but I suggest you so
we build it up again in this way what is
the objective what data is required and
also the different steps of the workflow
and then you can ever look through it
and we will still be available here and
you can also
ask any question so we said at the
beginning this is something very new for
us and so it was kind of our first
tutorial we also have a feedback form so
please give us feedback anyhow like
positive or negative especially negative
because then we can improve so yeah it
doesn't take two minutes it would be and
we would really appreciate it okay and
yeah I hope you liked it and I think
wouldn't have added we can only start
giving your ideas it's nonsense
you're not now certificate certifying
geospatial professional yes I think we
try to give you different aspects of it
and I hope maybe some part of it I
interested okay thank you
[Applause]
[Music]